it's great to welcome to the program
today charles whelan who is professor of
public policy
at dartmouth author of a number of books
many of which i've read including naked
economics naked money
naked statistics uh great to have you on
today
great i'm glad you've read all the naked
books that's how we refer to this series
so uh you taught well in the books you
talk a lot
particularly in naked economics and
naked money
about the impact and repercussions at a
macro
economic level of the government doing
things which include making adjustments
to the money supply
making money available in different ways
so maybe to pick something that's going
on now when you look at
the so-called coronavirus stimulus and
how that was administered partially to
individuals partially as loans partially
to corporations
what about it from a broad economic
standpoint was done correctly and what
was not so good
i think the best thing is that it put
money in the pockets
of people who needed it small businesses
and we'll get to how well it was
targeted because that anticipates i
think one of the weaknesses
and also consumers who are at risk of
missing rent payments being evicted
and the like one of the most intriguing
concepts in economics
is the paradox of thrift this idea that
when something
bad happens our natural and entirely
rational response
is to spend less to hang on to what we
have and of course as soon as we
hang on to what we have then we don't
buy a refrigerator don't buy a car don't
go out to dinner
and that's the income of all of those
folks they hang on more tightly and of
course more businesses
are in distress so somehow government
needs to
overcome that paradox of thrift now in
the financial crisis
the problem was that all our financial
institutions were paralyzed
nobody could get credit if you want to
go to a restaurant the restaurant was
open but
you know how can we open the spigots of
credit again
so the economy worked with covet we've
got an entirely different problem the
banking system is mercifully healthy
and many people went into covid in
pretty good financial shape
but they couldn't spend the money they
had because the restaurant was closed
so the challenge there was to keep those
restaurants afloat
until we could get through and i guess
we're now seeing the end of the tunnel
the pandemic just keep them afloat as
opposed to starting up say the financial
system again
yeah it seems when i look at the way
some european countries and other
countries handled this
they were more aggressive with the idea
of we will pay the salaries of your
employees
so that you don't lay anybody off i
think the idea being that there would be
less friction
in getting things back up to speed
because the the employees would still be
employees and
and so on do you think that that was not
done well enough in the us
i think our approach was probably a
little more scatter shot
some of the payments to businesses had
the effect of keeping employees
on the books on the other end i talked
to small business people
who faced a dilemma whereby if they were
kept on
at reduced salary their employees might
have done better if they went on
unemployment
right and so you created some kind of
tension there and then obviously what
we've been reading in the news in the
last couple weeks about
a high proportion of these payments
going to a small number of firms
i haven't delved into that but that does
get to
a question you always have to face which
is how well targeted is this
to the folks who really need support in
the near term that's priority number one
primary
priority number two is how well targeted
is it to the folks
who will continue to spend in ways that
keep other businesses healthy
and what what are the answers to those
two questions as far as
somebody else you know it strikes me as
given the time a lot of that it was
probably about a b-plus
okay you know we forget that nobody was
well it's not true nobody was planning
for this but it certainly wasn't what we
expected to come along
and when you've got to draw up something
like like this so quickly
and deal with the politics get it
through a very divided congress
i think we did actually reasonably well
up to the present where now again
we're arguing over what the next phase
of it ought to be yeah i mean i think
that
we can talk about the lack of pandemic
response readiness by the administration
on the more medical side getting rid of
the pandemic response team ignoring the
playbook etc
but the shock to the system from the
economic side would have been a shock
regardless it sounds like is what you're
saying
i think that's true and i think there's
some things that seem superficially
attractive
that have some downsides so for example
the moratorium
on evictions and moratorium things it
makes perfectly you do not want to be
throwing people out in the street in the
middle of the pandemic
on the other hand you do have to
appreciate that those folks are not
paying rent or not paying rent to other
small property owners who will then have
trouble so i you know i'm
much more comfortable with something
that substitutes for those rent payments
right so that there's no eviction
and therefore keeps the property owners
whole as opposed to just throwing the
thrust of the pain
on these small renters many of whom may
have just a couple of apartments that
are source of revenue
and if we say you can't evict them but
they're not paying you rent then you've
just
created a different level of distress
there is a perspective in economic
thinking
anytime you're talking about giving
people money
this applies to stimulus this applies to
programs like universal basic income
this applies to minimum wage increases
and the very general idea
is you devalue the currency when you
when you make it easier to get money
when you increase the supply of money
simple supply and demand suggests each
dollar becomes worth less
there's inflation and you end up
basically in the exact
same place can you talk now about
the additional knowledge we have
including from behavioral economics and
other types of economic thinking
that that makes that less cut and dry
well the one great puzzle of our time
pre-covered
is why we're not seeing more inflation
we have pumped
going back to the financial crisis up to
and including the covid response we have
pumped
just staggering amounts of money and
liquidity
into the pipes and we're barely
reaching our inflation target targets
and sometimes
failing to reach our inflation target so
if you went back to grad school
when i was in grad school in the early
90s at the university of chicago and
said
hey let me give you a hypothetical
experiment where we pump
trillions of dollars into the economy do
you think you're going to get price
increases or maybe even a little
deflation
everybody would have said that is
impossible we're still
trying to kind of work through that part
of the behavioral economics explanation
just let me say parenthetically i think
behavioral econ is one of the most
interesting and exciting
things to come along because it helps to
answer some of these questions
is that when you become conditioned to
stable prices for a long period of time
then it's harder to raise prices it's
the flip side of the 70s when everyone
just assumed hey we're going to raise
i don't care what's going on the macro
my prices are going up 15
this year just because that's what you
do in spring you know maybe we're seeing
the backside of that
there's some discussion about whether
globalization has just continued to
increase the global supply
so much that we can absorb the money and
and spend it around the world and the
the competition from china and vietnam
keeps prices low because american firms
can't raise prices it just
keeps that constant pressure my
colleague here danny blanchflower
has argued that a lot of the labor
market data are very misleading
unemployment looks really low but when
you delve into it a lot of folks are not
working as many
hours as they would like to they're
feeling more tenuously attached to the
labor market
and then he's found this interesting
thing where if you ask people
how likely they are to be fired or lose
their job
they overstayed it by like five-fold
you know because you can then follow
them and find out how many of them are
actually fired
what that means is that they are very
reticent to ask for more money
because they feel that their job is more
precarious than it actually is and that
is another thing
keeping prices low so it's probably some
combination of these things
but i suspect that if you come up with
some unifying theory
of why all this money flowing into the
system hasn't led to more inflation you
will certainly be on the nobel short
list
well on on the other side of this
example that we're seeing
in i think in both naked economics and
money although you'll you'll correct me
you often use my birth country of
argentina
as an example of disasters when it comes
to currency i mean we've had we had
you know the peg the dollar peso peg
which completely
failed hyper inflation not at the level
of of like zimbabwe
or venezuela but but still pretty bad
all these terrible situations when it
comes to currency
what seems to be the tipping point where
those
cascading currency disasters happen in
countries
i think the difference between argentina
and most places in the world
yeah is that there's just not a lot of
credibility people don't believe the
central bank
they don't believe the fiscal
authorities and a lot of monetary policy
is about credible commitment that you
say you're going to do something you do
it the markets
respond in ways that if they believe you
reinforce what's going to happen so
when the chair of the fed in the united
states says we're serious about
inflation
we're not going to get let prices rise
faster than two percent ever
well then people don't raise their
prices because they assume that the fed
would fight that back and
it becomes a self-reinforcing prophecy
when
the monetary authorities in argentina
say hey we're going to fight inflation
when everybody's done laughing they say
yeah yeah we've seen this movie 11 times
before
i don't i mean it's been a long time
since i wrote naked money
we were going to put a whole chapter on
argentina in instead we just used a lot
of examples
yeah that i'm glad you didn't do the
whole chapter that would have been that
would have been more devastating
um so so when it comes to um in in naked
money when you talk about the
credibility of money
as you're kind of talking about in the
context of argentina you do address
cryptocurrency and you
and you take head on some of the um
bullet points that we hear
from some of the anti-cryptocurrency
people such as it doesn't have
inherent value and you explain that you
know the idea of
gold having inherent value is also less
clear maybe uh
than some people point out what's your
sense now
since the book was written about
cryptocurrency
we've seen you know early in the
pandemic people
expecting bitcoin to go crazy were
disappointed that it didn't but then in
the last
few months we've actually seen
significant increase in the in the value
of bitcoin
what's your sense of it now i'm still
not very sold on the idea that bitcoin
is here for the long run
for a number of reasons i mean part of
you you expect money to do
a number of things and i don't think
bitcoin does any of them very well so
one
is as a unit of exchange and this is the
easiest one where it's clearly failed
i mean part of the reason that we use
dollars and not argentine pesos is we
have a pretty good idea
of what the dollar is going to be worth
next year even 10 years i mean maybe
plus or minus 2
but it really doesn't move a whole lot
yeah when bitcoin right when people say
wow bitcoins on aurora it's up 400
that's not a good thing from the
standpoint of money now if you invested
in it you made a lot of money
but the point of money is i'm gonna buy
a house
and i'm gonna say you know david i'm
gonna give you
a hundred bitcoins a year for the next
30 years that's the way a mortgage works
now if those bitcoins go up 400 percent
value my mortgage payment just went up
four percent so
it's very hard for us to contract using
a monetary
thing you know that's fluctuating but
even if it's going up you just want
something stable now
the other things that we look for are is
it a good store of value
that one i think is also uncertain yes
it's gained value but it's also
plummeted at times
on that one charles after how many years
of of at least
it retaining some value would we be able
to say that the store of value
requirement is met
i don't know if it's a number of years i
think it's the pers the percentage of
people who are persuaded that it will
hold its value i mean because as you
correctly pointed out
it's all whether i believe that it has
value and if i do
then i'll use it so um certainly more
than it used to yeah
um and then the last one is kind of as a
unit of account or not as a universe but
as a medium of exchange so
how easy is it to do transactions and
it's still much easier for me to use a
credit card
or use cash than it is for bitcoin i've
got to go buy the bitcoins and so
well i guess let me push back slightly
on that one in the
in the last year i mean now just like my
credit card's linked up with my phone
and i can swipe it
i can link bitcoin with my phone with
instant dollar conversions and swipe at
the same time so it's definitely
changed a lot of progress has been made
and i would say you know if you're
in a place like venezuela or you're in a
place where
everything is just crumbling around you
then bitcoin might serve some of these
purposes better
than for me sitting here in new
hampshire right you've got to park
wealth someplace you got to move it
out of the country quickly so it
certainly has a purpose now
i'll add one other caveat that may be my
biggest concern
which is at present it's bitcoin is a
really handy medium of exchange for
people doing really nefarious things so
we just had a huge
hack of a hospital system in vermont
one of these ransomware things where
it's you know pay us x millions of
dollars
or will destroy all your systems and of
course the payment they want is in
bitcoin
which is terrific for them you know i do
have some concerns
from the bitcoin standpoint about if
this becomes the medium of exchange for
people doing bad
things then there might be some
regulatory crackdown on it
in which case it becomes less attractive
as a currency for everybody else
yeah that's interesting i mean i i i for
me the biggest concerns remain
in many cases transaction fees and the
the unpredictable
value the it's used for crime stuff i
mean when silk road was shut down which
was believed to be a huge piece of the
bitcoin market
the bitcoin market barely was affected
in number of transactions or volume it
seemed to be a much smaller piece of it
and also by the way i mean most crimes
are are being committed involving
dollars most racketeering is happening
so that one is not super strong for me
but the logistics of
of it and the volatility seem to be my
biggest concerns i don't know
yeah and you know i think bubbles are
interesting you never know for sure if
you're in a bubble until it's over so in
2005 i thought the property prices were
frothy
yeah but i didn't short the property
market it would have been kind of hard
to do
i also thought that amazon was wildly
overpriced
i was right on one of those things and
terribly wrong on the other
so you know i think time will tell but i
love the discussion because i think
bitcoin forces us to think about what
money is
why are the pieces of paper issued by
the argentine government
different than the pieces of paper
issued by the american government
because it's all just paper
thinking about the next five years
10 years what types of systemic
changes do you anticipate to economic
and financial systems that are a result
of
either technological change or cultural
change like the big
picture things i think the biggest
question
is what the next phase of capitalism
looks like
we're not going to go socialist you know
i'm old enough to have lived through the
soviet union i traveled there i've been
to cuba
that's not the future on the other hand
i think i teach a lot of young people
who look around and say well something's
not quite right i mean why is the
richest country in the history of
civilization why are people living on
the streets
uh clearly what the populace of both the
left and the right both trump and bernie
who when you parse it are saying some of
the same things
different policy but same similar
rhetoric yeah right so
exactly not the diagnosis is broadly
similar
they are reflecting the fact that
despite great wealth and over the
my lifetime enormous growth in the
economy and incomes
people feel very insecure and they feel
not fully happy with the level of
disruption and of course we're looking
at a.i and other things coming down the
pike
so i think the question for people who
are center right and center
left so not the socialist not the
nationalist populous
is how do we tighten the safety net
so that the folks who we know are being
disrupted
or will be disrupted can kind of bounce
back
into this vibrant growing economy
without just hitting the ground
and interestingly i think you know
center left has always talked about this
when you look at the scandinavian
countries they're they're actually
robust capitalist economies yes they
just have a tighter safety net
right but i think it's going to become
more interesting for center right there
are folks like oren cass who's a
conservative thinker
who's talking more about the role that
unions might play from a conservative
standpoint
to give workers more voice i think
there's going to be a lot of
fresh thinking about how we harness
everything that is great about
capitalism
and there's a lot there while we sew
the holes up that are clearly the the
failures and deficiencies
or in cast i'll have to i'll have to
just do a little reading up
hey before i let you go i recently read
the book
station 11 by emily st john mandel which
is
pandemic literature and also beautiful
writing
absolutely fantastic book fantastic book
uh you've
written the rationing also uh about a
global pandemic this is like a genre now
pandemic literature
lawrence wright who's another terrific
writer wrote a book
i think the end of october which is
about a pandemic so yes my book the
rationing is about who gets the vaccine
right during a pandemic and just to
point out it was written in 2019
yes so yes it is you know part of the
reason it's a genre
is the same reason that apocalypse
movies or a genre is we're fascinated
by how we behave as humans in adverse
circumstances why we watch war movies
over and over again
so it wasn't that it was a genius about
the pandemic that was just a convenient
tool right for looking at the political
response it's really a political
thriller
that's the rationing we've been speaking
with charles whelan professor of public
policy at dartmouth
also check out the naked books naked
economics naked money naked statistics i
i so appreciate your time today
oh it's great to talk to you